hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar overcoming challenges
in the cellular therapy laboratory I am
Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website a provider of virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by two room OB CT to room OB CT
is a global leader in blood component
therapeutic a phoresis and cellular
technologies it is the only company with
the unique combination of a phoresis
collections manual and automated whole
blood processing and pathogen reduction
technologies Teramo BCT believes in the
potential of blood to do even more for
patients than it does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about Teramo BCT please visit
www.opm.gov/health refresh in your mind
to do so simply type them into the Q&A
box which will open when you click the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Patrick Handley
PhD dr. Henley is the laboratory
facility director and an assistant
professor at Children's National Health
System and George Washington University
he oversees the class 10,000 GMT
facility at Children's National which is
charged with manufacturing novel
cellular therapies in the program for
cell enhancement and technology for
immunotherapy Seki under IND
applications and processing standard of
care stem cell transplant products dr.
Hanley is also responsible for follow-up
in
reconstitution testing performed on
patients treated on SETI's protocols he
has been involved in more than 15
clinical trials in the past 10 years
dr. Henley has been recognized as a
developing expert in the field of
cellular therapy and cellular therapy
product manufacturing he was granted the
excellence in research award by the
American Society of gene and cell
therapy in 2012 and the Young
Investigator award by the International
Society for cell therapy in 2013 and
2016 in 2017 he was awarded the Be The
Match American Society of blood and
marrow transplantation a mr. elderman a
cebit
award dr. Henley is passionate about
developing dedicated training programs
for cellular service particularly
programs dedicated to training
scientists in positions within the
cellular therapy laboratory his complete
bio is found on the labyrinth website
dr. Henley will now begin his
presentation all right welcome everyone
thank you for the opportunity to present
my talk today titled overcoming
challenges in the cellar therapy
laboratory my name is Patrick Hanley and
again I'm the laboratory director at
Children's National Hospital before we
begin I do want to disclose that I have
a disclosure I am a co-founder and vice
president of mana therapeutics and I
hold equity in mana therapeutics which
is a new startup company that generates
tumor specific t-cells targeting AML
that are not genetically modified so the
FERC Trust provides a foundation for my
talk today I wanted to use bone marrow
transplant as a model for cellular
therapies so bone marrow transplant is
the treatment of choice for many
hematologic malignancies as well as some
genetic disorders unfortunately the
necessary Mylo blade of regimen and
conditioning for these transplants
really leave the patients susceptible to
viral infections as well as relapse and
also graft-versus-host disease so I
wanted to use bone marrow transplant as
a model to develop therapies to treat
these different complications so again
those are viral infection relapse in the
case
patients that have cancer and also
graft-versus-host disease where the
graft attacks the the recipient the way
that we target these complications is by
using tumor specific t-cells virus
specific t-cells and mesenchymal stromal
cells so to begin I'll talk about the
virus specific t-cells and these have
been developed by Anne lien at Clio
Rooney Helen Heslov and others at Baylor
College of Medicine and it's to the
point now where we can actually just
take peripheral blood mononuclear cells
so we'll take about fifteen or twenty
milliliters of peripheral blood isolate
the PBMCs and expose those DBM C's to
overlapping viral peptides derived from
the viruses of interest in this case
cytomegalovirus epstein-barr virus and
Edna virus because those are the three
greatest viral complications after
transplant at least in our experience so
once those PBMCs are exposed to peptides
we also add the growth factors
interleukin 4 and interleukin 7 and
after about 10 days we're able to
harvest the virus specific T cells these
T cells of course under girls Cyrilla t
testing testing for mycoplasma endotoxin
l reactivity viability as well as HLA to
ensure that the identity of those cells
is is important with the original cells
that we started with and this is what
you would expect to see when you give
virus evictee cells based on the the
last 25 years of data so shown in red is
the viral load of a patient who had an e
BB infection you can see that this
patient was treated with rituximab and
they did not respond so we decided to
give them a BB specific t-cells outer
part of that virus we T cells mine I
just talked about you see in red there's
an increase in the EBV Civic T cells we
give the T cells and there's a quick
decline in the viral load of EB be in
the peripheral blood of this patient
when we taste them when we test the
peripheral blood of the patient for EBV
our EBV specific T cells shown in blue
you can see that there's a coinciding
increase in the number of EBV specific T
cells in that patient
this is a hallmark of what we expect to
see if we're going to see a a virus to
Turkey cell response so again this
patient this protocol is here at
Children's National we've treated 22
patients the response rate is greater
than 80 percent most patients that come
to us had refractory disease with few
other options in fact I'd say that we
get about two referrals a week for
patients who have refractory viral
infection post transplant and they don't
have many other options and so they come
asking if we have a protocol open to
give these patients viruses and t-cells
so now we're planning to open and we
have opened a new protocol called Matt
where we target dk virus hhv-6
and parainfluenza and that's in addition
to the CMV EVB and a device that we had
targeted before so these are now hexa
virus specific t-cells
so that's great if you have a donor of
the bone marrow transplant that you go
to get to make the cells from and treat
the recipient but what if you don't have
the donor what if it's a cord blood
transplant and you have a patient that
has reactivation of CMV how can you
proceed other t-cells that we can use
and the answer is yes so we can use
third party t-cells what we can do is we
can take those cells that we originally
made and the first protocol I told you
about and Bank them so now we have a
bank of something like 42 different EBV
CMV and I know by our Civic t cell lines
that we can choose from based on the a
gelée of the recipient as well as the
virus if ik activity of those lines
through those shared alleles those HLA
alleles so we have a third party t-cell
protocol open here at Children's
National that's open to recipients of a
bone marrow transplant 30 days after the
transplant we treated 12 patients on
this study and the overall response rate
is 72 percent so not altogether
different than the donor derived cells
that we mentioned earlier and it's of
importance these cells are potentially
available immediately so if we were to
get a referral today we could
theoretically treat the patient tomorrow
or the next day depending on the
location of that that recipient
and if we again look at that hallmark of
a virus to t-cell response you can see
here the viral load of this patient into
space in this instance the patient had a
no virus that is shown in red shortly
after the T cell infusion were able to
detect
adenovirus Civic T cells in the
peripheral blood of that patient and
these are both shown in blue hexa and
Penton are both proteins derived of at
omar's so i have shown you that we can
generate T cells of target viruses and
we can actually use third party T cell
targeting viruses so it seems like we
have some options to combat or treat or
prevent viral infections post transplant
but what about patients who are coming
to transplant because of leukemia or
other malignancies well we're now
generating tumor specific T cells as
another option so to generate these T
cells we use a similar protocol to the
varsity T cells but it's a bit more
complicated and you can imagine the
varsity T cells the majority of those
donors have memory T cells that we can
easily expand in the presence of those
viral antigens
however tumor specific t-cells we've
shown actually come from the naive
population of T cells so they require
priming and additional simulations
beyond just the one stimulation in the
case of the virus T cell and so what
that looks like is shown here
we take peripheral blood from the
transplant donor we take probably
upwards of 100 milliliters 120
milliliters in 1 or 2 blood draws from
those peripheral blood mononuclear cells
we generate mana monitor clear so excuse
me monocytes and dendritic cells from
the adherent fraction so we just put the
BBN C's on to plastic they adhere we
give them some gm-csf and aisle 4 and
they'll form dendritic cells we harvest
the not adherent cells which contains
your T cells and we freeze those back
for when we need them during the T cell
stimulation so after seven days of
generation self-generation we pulse
those tender excels with the Leukemia
estrogens or tumor associated antigens
made excuse me
frame wt1 and survivin so there's three
of three entities that we target
so dendritic cells are folks with those
three antigens and they're used to
stimulate the t-cells that come from
that crowd observed fraction that we
talked about before concurrently we also
generate dendritic cells for a second
round of stimulation so in seven days
after that initial stimulation will give
a second stimulation with the dendritic
cells pulses those same peptides the
third stimulation what we use are
activated t-cells or pH a blast and so
we'll pulse those same T cells those
same also the details of those same
peptides for the third stimulation so
after about thirty days we've generated
tumor specific t-cells and so these are
the interim results of this study so
this study was open to both pediatric
and adult patients many of whom had
received a hep low identical transplant
I think we are we're all surprised to
see that of the ten evaluable patients
fifty of them had a complete response
including for patients with AML which
you don't typically see so the recently
approved Novartis car t-cell for example
is targeted at a ll not AML so here we
have a different option twenty percent
of those patients had persistent disease
and twenty percent of them had stable
disease including progressive disease
and ten head mineral residuals excuse me
mixer strong it's important to point out
that the prognosis of these patients who
is not good so all these patients had
failed a bone marrow transplant at least
once many of them many times and they
were all extremely high-risk we would
not expect a life expectancy of these
patients to be very long and to see that
there's many of them are still alive
today is is it's really encouraging so
I've shown you that we have far Civic T
so we have tumor specific T cells but
what about graft-versus-host disease how
can we treat graft-versus-host disease
so one way to treat graft-versus-host
disease and this is nothing new
many studies have been done using MSDS
but when an option is to use the MSE so
they're adherent non-traumatic
multipotent stem cells or or stromal
cells the different change counterblast
adipocytes and osteoblasts so one unique
property of these MSDS is they don't
express hla class ii molecules Okura co
co stimulatory molecules so they we can
use banked MSDS and they would persist
long enough to potentially deliver a
clinical benefit so ii each recipient
would not need their own MSE donor
what makes MSE is particularly appealing
in the graft-versus-host disease setting
is that they're both immunosuppressive
and regenerative so they can suppress
the immune response ER or the the
graft-versus-host disease and also help
repair any damage that was already done
but of course manufacturing MSC's is
quite challenging so what you see on the
right is a former staff member
my dad baylor college of medicine where
in she's preparing to harvest 200 flasks
to make the MSDS so that's an entire
double stack of incubators full of
blasts with MSC's it's labor intensive
there's a limited cultural life so you
want to reduce the number of passages of
these MSDS but that's a bit of a
conundrum because you need to pass it in
multiple times in order to reach your
cell dose and this is what that
manufacturing paradigm looks like in a
cartoon fashion so you would start with
say four blasts and end up with many
hundreds of blasts so we set out to
improve this manufacturing process and
it was a nice partnership with thermo
where we were able to generate these
MSDS using the cell quantum cell
expansion system so this is a mostly
automated system with 2.1 square meters
of surface area which is about 120 T 155
lat
it has the optimal exchange of gas and
nutrients and it's functionally close so
theoretically you could put multiple
Quantum's in one room and generate
different lots of em
of course given regulatory approval what
I really like about the quantum is that
has a rapid harvest time so you can
imagine harvesting 300 T 175 blasts
would take you probably five or six
hours with five people the harvest in
the quantum is at most 45 minutes and
it's a touch of a button and this is
what the quantum looks like inside so
you have a bioreactor which is shown at
the bottom I like to say that that's a
Pringles can
so that Pringles cannons and full of
straws or the hollow fiber bioreactors
the straws are what's shown at the top
and that's where the MSC's gross they
grow inside of each one of the straws
and there's about 10,000 of those straws
against the hollow fiber hollow fibers
inside of the bioreactor and that's how
you get that large surface area and this
is what a manufacturing paradigm would
look like at least a couple years ago
when we published this paper so do
encode the quantum was fibronectin you
would then load in your bone marrow into
the quantum after one passage she was
out in triple select or whatever your
dissociation reagent is you would
harvest the MSC so we would harvest
somewhere around 50 million msds you
could then coat the bioreactor was high
protected for four hours and then reload
about 20 million of those MSDS and
depending on whatever media you're using
and growth factors and things like that
and of course the donor you could
harvest as many as 600 million MSC's
again this was this was about three or
four years ago so the question we asked
was actually not in graft-versus-host
disease but it was a partnership with
someone in houston where we wanted to
manufacture these cells for his he mixed
robe and so we said okay well we can
grow two to three million msds per class
and so you know this was in Texas where
everything is bigger and arguably better
so we would need about 500 million MSDS
for each patient and that's about 200 T
175 last so what we're trying to show
here is even if we use glass this is a
feasible approach to manufacture these
MSDS for this trial
we wanted to improve on that we didn't
want to spend the five hours and five
people harvesting embassies so we said
well can we use the quantum and so we
tested various lots of embassies in both
flasks and the quantum and what this
slide here shows is that we were able to
generate more msds faster in the quantum
than in Flast
so in black is in the quantum and a gray
is in class and at this time we were
able to generate a median or a mean of
600 or 700 million MSC s after only two
passages whereas in the quantum we
needed three to five to get half that
number when you look at MSC s you
typically define them by their phenotype
as well as a tri lineage potential and
so here we looked at the hallmark
phenotype of MSC s including CD 105 C 90
and CD w3 and you can see here that the
viability in both MSC in both class and
the quantum was quite similar one of the
questions we asked as well is the
doubling time difference so why is the
quantum allowing for more cells quicker
than class is it because the cells are
doubling faster or fewer cells are dying
or what is the answer and the answer
seems to be that the cells in in quantum
have a similar doubling time than in
Flast but perhaps it's slightly higher
we also test the MSDS for colony forming
units which is another characteristic of
embassies and we did see a trend towards
higher CF use in the quantum
importantly we analyze the function of
these embassies so there's many
different ways to analyze the function
of embassies and oftentimes it depends
on what your downstream application is
so if you're looking at some sort of
regenerative medicine potential maybe
you need to do the try lineage potential
you know if you're looking at bone then
you do the osteogenic potential so we
were interested in the immunosuppressive
capabilities of the MS es so we set up
an assay but some of our collaborators
through pact where we analyzed the
ability of the T cells to suppress
t-cell proliferation and you can see
here that the MSC is grown in both glass
and the quantum seemed to equally or
similarly inhibit the proliferation of
the T cells and of course perhaps the
most important functional tests of these
MFCs is an in vivo model so these we
want to this application was for receive
an ischemic stroke and so we tested
these MSC's in a model of ischemic
stroke in rats and so that's shown here
we tested quantum drive Gemma sees
plaster eyes MSDS as well as a saline
and what you can see is that the
therapeutic benefit of the MSE is grown
in quantum was better than in flasks and
just saline alone and I mentioned
earlier that what I was showing the data
was from 2014 well here's what that
looks like today so we made some
improvements in RMS degeneration and
here is what it looks like so sometimes
we have to start for using flats for the
first or second passage due to the
amount of bone marrow that we can get
from it's the leftover bone marrow from
transplant donors but nevertheless we
can load bone marrow into the quantum
for passage one will get about 25 to 55
million cells and for passage to will
reload about 20 million cells and
recover 800 million cells we then reload
20 million cells again for passage 3 and
we recover 1.1 billion cells so you can
imagine that we're able to build quite a
sizable Bank using just one lot of bone
marrow
so here's where we are today we can
manufacture donor drive by our Civic
t-cells to prevent or treat viral
infection and those cells seems to be
quite effective we can deliver
third-party buyer sue t-cells with a
similar efficacy and almost immediately
we can also manufacture tumor associated
antigen specific t-cells and these have
an overall response rate of 75% again
which is we were quite surprised by with
a complete response rate of 50% and this
is not altogether different than the
response rates you see with the chimeric
antigen receptors that have already been
approved by the FDA and we're looking to
pursue that now lastly we can
manufacture MSDS for various indications
including graft-versus-host disease as
well as this quemic stroke but
manufacturing these cells is still not
easy it takes a lot of time takes a lot
of effort takes a lot of people and so
there's still a few challenges that we
need to overcome so how do we move
beyond transplant how do we afford to
make all these products if we're making
three products for every recipient of a
bone-marrow transplant that's going to
be pretty expensive
you saw the cost of the cars at 375 for
$475,000 you can imagine that a similar
cost for three products it'd be upwards
of a million dollars and how do we make
three products for patient you can
imagine the space that would be required
so how do we move beyond transplant well
one option is actually to use the tumor
associated antigen t-cells I talked
about but for solid tumors instead of
Leukemia post transplant and that's
something we are pursuing we're also
looking at using those t-cells before a
transplant to get the patient in
remission and then keep them
intermission you might have heard that
car t-cells are being looked at in the
same fashion to use them as a bridge for
transplant and that's an option for
these t-cells as well we are also
generating HIV specific t-cells he's
targeting gag pollen nap for
hiv-positive recipients and I think our
hiv-positive patients and I think that's
encouraging we're using MSDS for
inflammatory bowel disease and of course
chimeric antigen receptors which we've
talked about a bit before
so one challenge is how can we afford to
make these products so much of this work
that's been happening for 25 years in
the case of the buyer Civic t-cell is no
longer innovative so you know if you
apply for a grant you say look I need
these cells because we need to treat
treat the recipients you know the
reviewers will say well this has been
around for 25 years what's different
but the conundrum we have is that we get
referrals each week from patients or
from physicians across the country who
say I have this patient they are their
family again cycle here their failed
bhaskar net we don't have any options
can you enroll them on your trial so
we're literally treating these patients
at a cost to our center because we care
about the well-being of these patients
so the cost of these of these therapies
is prohibitive but we still need to find
a mechanism to treat these patients who
who need these options so some companies
have now started to use these antibiotic
cells
Mataura for example virus site and so it
is encouraging that they might have
options but we still need to find a way
to afford a spot these products one
option for companies for institutions is
cost recovery so this is actually a
thing the FDA has sanctioned cost
recovery if there are extraordinary
costs associated with manufacturing the
products but it's important to recognize
that these are only the direct costs to
a CEO of manufacturing products and not
the cost of tracking the patients and
things like that so it is limited also
the FDA doesn't tell you how to recover
those funds so you'll have to work with
your hospital to find a mechanism to
either get the insurance company to
reimburse or perhaps another hospital
another option is to convince your
hospital that is cheaper or drives
revenue elsewhere this gives potentially
easier in Europe but it also is an
option in the United States so if you
have a patient who has to come to get
tumor specific t-cells and maybe they
have to have an inpatient stay there's
probably other costs associated with
that state that will drive revenue
especially if that patient were to
receive a bone-marrow transplant at that
same institution
another option is to make the products
cheaper so if if the cells are al
generic or banked as we've discussed
earlier those cells will be cheaper that
if you have to make a specific product
or fertilize product for every single
recipient so we are looking at that
alginate model for T cells and
parameters it's also important to
educate physicians and the clinical
staff as a whole about the cost of these
products so a lot of these physicians
have grown up in the environment that
we've fostered where they have access to
a lot of these innovative cell therapies
but they might not know the cost
generating them or the time that staff
has to make have to take to make them so
we waste about 50% of our products
because patients are enrolled who are
unlikely to ever receive them and this
is a major product major problem for us
so staff in our facility spend a
considerable amount of time effort
making these cells and they do that they
work in to stay work in this academic
setting not because they're trying to
make a lot of money but because they're
really invested in health care they want
to improve the outcomes of the patients
and they're really excited by the
innovative therapies that we offer but
if half of their products are never used
that really impacts their their morale
and so there is room to educate the
physicians about how to how to only
enroll patients who are likely to get
these these products so how do we
manufacture all these products well one
way is to build a massive GMP facility
which was not the case for us so you can
see here on the Left there's a small
room that is our ISO 7 facility that's
dedicated solely to manufacturing ing
products the second room is in ISO 80 to
request 100,000 facility used for
stem-cell processing we will use the ISO
8 room in the case of overflow and it
does operate closer to ISO 6 than ISO 8
but nevertheless we don't have a lot of
manufacturing space so we have to find
creative ways to manufacture all these
products given the space
we manufacture about 75 imd products a
year and 75 stem-cell products here we
have about a hundred and fusions per
year and actually looking at our data
it's probably closer to 125 150 now
because of the demand for these novel
cell therapies that were manufacturing
what I think is really exciting is that
we're embarking on multiple multicenter
clinical trials in fact we were the
first GOG cell therapy study to ever be
run we're the manufacturing centre for
that and that was a huge accomplishment
for us but you can imagine the amount of
time and effort it took to get this up
and running and to qualify all the sites
we're now looking to do a nationwide
clinical trial using the virus living
t-cells in collaboration with the
pediatric bone marrow transplant
consortium and so we're really excited
about that trial as well but it's going
to take a lot of time and effort from
staff so adding a lot of these new
protocols and cell types is a massive
hurdle for us so how do we manufacture
all of them well as I mentioned before
it's important to educate the physician
and fidgets and prioritize the high-risk
patients so is this patient likely to
get our therapy if so then yeah
absolutely let's enroll them
let's make those cells for them and
let's hope for the best another option
is to stagger into shifts working on
weekends and we're starting to do this
it's hard to justify more space when
your space is only being used for a
third of the time it could be utilized
the next thing is to hire and retain
fantastic and passionate staff and this
is definitely challenging giving given
the assignment and and money being spent
in the cell therapy arena but I'm very
fortunate to have passionate dedicated
staff who are really invested in
manufacturing the products for the
patients you don't require a lot of a
lot of individual attention they can
handle a lot of the scheduling and
things like that on their own and so I'm
really grateful for having such
fantastic staff and that's a key to
being able to run a high functioning
facility but that's still not enough I
think what we really need is to improve
the manufacturing methods so one example
is the tumor associate answered t-cells
that I talked about I'm really
encouraged that
the overall response rate is around 75%
for these patients that 50% of them have
a complete response but it takes one
month to generate these T cells it also
takes two blood products this process
needs to be short and if it can be
automated then that's all the better I
think my vision is to have twenty
Quantum's twenty prodigies twenty ways
whatever it is in one room up you know
generating twenty different lines
simultaneously with a process that
prevents contamination or mixed up of
course that's an FDA regulation but it
doesn't need twenty different clean
rooms and we need to you know that's the
futures out there we need to be able to
get this another option or another
example is the virus to be T cells from
cord blood so it's my understanding that
we're the first and only group to give
bio Civic T cells derived from cord
blood which is primarily naive T cells
but this process takes two or three
months because it takes one to two
months to generate the e BB LCL that are
used to generate the T cells so we came
up with a method of using activated PHA
blasts or activated T cells instead of
the LCL and so we've shortened that
process to 30 days it's still not ten
days it takes for the rapid T cells that
we can make but we're getting there
another option is to automate and so
that goes back to what I was talking
about earlier where we have 20 different
instruments manufacturing in parallel
and one one designated controlled
airspace and so that's where I'd like to
go now so I've shown you earlier that we
can generate MSC's in the quanto I will
say I'm not employed by turbo I don't I
don't get any royalties by to remote but
I can unequivocally say that if we did
not use the quantum we would not have an
MSD program here at Children's because
we don't have the space or the personnel
to manufacture 200 T 175 blasts and so
I'm hoping to use that same technology
to grow T cells as well
so how would be able to manufacture the
car t-cells in the quantum well as I
mentioned the quantum is automated it's
self-contained as a small footprint
which is very attractive for that model
I talked about earlier we are
comfortable using it we use it for the
MSDS so we have knowledge of it
we already purchased the disposables for
the MSDS and thermo does have an
excellent training program that will
help work with us to generate these
t-cells of course we can generate 1
billion or more MSDS so I would expect
that we can probably generate 10 or 20
billion t-cells given that t-cells are
considerably smaller than the MSDS and
so this was the this was the design of
our car t-cell project we want to
evaluate the expansion of mononuclear
cells derived t-cells in the quantum and
it flasks evaluated transduction and
expansion of the car t-cells in quantum
and classical and then evaluate the
expansion of peripheral blood drive
t-cells in the quantum so we just
started this recently so I don't have a
lot of data to show but I think it is
promising these cells currently were
expanded from an A for instance product
purchased by key biologics we expand
them using dynabeads in the presence of
il-2 the media West xmax we've since
used switch to a our PMI and FBS FBS
based model due to costs and an
expansion potential and this is what we
were looking at so we loaded 100 million
Mondovi ourselves is a quantum and after
nine days we were able to recover about
6 billion t-cells so you can see that
that is a promising expansion we've
since optimized the protocol to get an
even greater expansion in a shorter
amount of time which is very encouraging
when we rate when we compared the
plastic quantum these were using crabs
reserved moderately ourselves you can
see that the expansion in the quantum is
indeed greater than in flasks this is
day 12 because the cells will crowd
preserved as I mentioned so there there
does seem to be a lag phase in the crop
reserved dry products versus the fresh
derived products and we're continuing to
evaluate the expansion now and also
evaluate the ability
transduce these t-cells in the quantum
so in conclusion cell therapies are
promising but expensive and
labor-intensive therapy and they're also
very spent space intensive they're
promising even beyond the transplant
model which is really encouraging for
the field there are ways definitely that
there are ways to increase efficiency
and manufacturing capability through
automation and creative thinking I think
we shouldn't be limited to only using
qualified airspace for every single
product you know there has to be a
better way to manufacture me so and I
think it will be a partnership with us
with industry working with the FDA to
find the most cost effective way to do
that and lastly we're evaluating whether
we can translate our knowledge from
embassies to grow P cells and car T
cells in the quantum and so with that
I'd like to thank everyone who's been
involved in this project so our program
director dr. Kat Fowler has been
incredibly supportive of all of these
protocols since we started this new
century program about four years ago
here in DC dr. Kirsten Williams is the
PI of the tumor specific T cell protocol
and she's been instrumental in really
transforming that protocol and is
commonly shares the data for me to
present to you today dr. Mike Kelley
Keller is the PI of the buyer Civic
t-cells and he has also kindly supplied
all that data and really taken that
protocol and run with it I'd like to
thank Tomita our our regulatory director
as well as my incredible staff in cell
therapy lab I could not be more
fortunate to have the staff that I do
and as well as Robert already has really
led the quantum t-cell work lastly I'd
like to have a shameless plug we are
trying to we are hosting a postdoc
position for someone to train to be a
facility director I should point out
that I was fortunate enough to have a
very similar situation when I was at
Baylor College of Medicine so I was able
to generate fire specific t-cells as a
graduate student because I was so
interested in it I did a postdoc with
Adrian Jie who was our facility director
GMP regulations and just
training on being a GMP director after
only two years I was able to come to
children's national where I'm now the
facility director here and I'd like to
replicate that same training position
for someone so if you know anyone please
have them email me at P Hanley
at Children's National org I'm really
committed to developing the next
generation of cell therapists because I
feel like there is really a shortage of
knowledgeable staff to fill these these
positions so with that thank you very
much and I'll turn it back over to our
organizers thank you dr. Hanley for your
presentation before we begin the
question and answer session I want to
advise a series of poll questions will
appear on your screen during the Q&A so
you may select your answers and close
the poll questions by clicking on the X
in the right corner so here's a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Hanley will
answer as many questions as time permits
and the first question is I see that
you've been able to expand t-cells in
the quantum do you foresee any
challenges or complications when trying
to transduce t-cells in the quantum or
expand gene modified cells in the
quantum that's a good question and I
think if I was doing this on my own I
would I would definitely be more
concerned that it was not going to work
just because of the sheer engineering
that goes into the quantum and
understanding the fluidics and
everything like that but fortunately you
know two Romo is really invested in
developing this technology so they've
been a great partner of ours in the past
and I believe that some groups have
transduced not only adherent cells which
would theoretically be easier but also
cells that are in suspension so they
don't have experience in transducing T
cells per se but I think that given our
expertise and our knowledge as well as
theirs we can certainly find a way to do
this and that's you know we're hoping to
have this data ready in the next couple
months
do you see cytokine release syndrome in
patients receiving your tumor associated
antigen specific T cells
that's a great question and you just
sort of keep this one up for me so one
of the benefits of not using genetically
modified T cells is that those T cells
are not hyper activated they don't have
artificial signaling domains or
exogenous signaling domains so we do not
see the tumor lysis syndrome or at least
we have not yet seen the tumor lysis
syndrome and the majority of our
patients have not had any adverse events
either so this is a potentially this
potential alternative to using the cars
and that we don't see the crs while we
do see elimination of the tumor burden
it could be that the tempo of
elimination of the tumor burden is
slower than the cars I think you know we
still need to evaluate that but one
benefit is the safety profile of these T
cells what do you think needs to happen
in order to make these therapies more
widespread and how will manufacturing
facilities be able to keep up yeah so I
mean that was really the basis of my
talk right right now I think the reason
there's only a select number of
specialized manufacturing facilities is
because you have to have so much
knowledge of how not only to manufacture
these cells but how to you submit the
IND to the FDA how do you handle adverse
events how do you train the physician
scientists to be able to handle the
protocol there's just so much knowledge
that needs that you need to have that
you really require a large specialized
center but in terms of just the
manufacturing itself which by the way I
think is why we need training programs
in cell therapy but in terms of
manufacturing itself I think what we
need are more automated systems
I think the G Rex for example was really
transformative for our group as well as
Baylor and many others you know it isn't
a complex bioreactor that requires
electronics it's it basically looks like
a mushroom
it's a flask but it has the gas exchange
through the bottom instead of the top so
you can basically add as much media and
cytokines as you want and don't have to
feed nearly as often and that was
transformative because suddenly we can
grow hundreds of millions of cells
without cell factories or without using
10:24 well plates so I think we need the
simple
the process I think we need to automate
the process or at least make it simple
enough that other groups can do it and I
really think that the buyer specific
t-cells are a good model so even if
those viruses t-cells are not put into
an automated system it's so simple that
other groups can do it you just take the
PBMCs mix them with overlapping casaya
libraries give them a couple of
cytokines and wait 10 days and harvest
them of course the testing of those
cells is a bit more complicated but you
know they're you know we and others are
more than willing to collaborate and
help develop those with you are there
advantages of using your tumor
associated antigen specific t-cells
instead of genetically modified cells
yeah so one benefit as I mentioned was
that these cells do not have them a much
better safety profile at least to date
we've only we're completing our phase
one so you know we haven't reported that
data yet but they have a better safety
profile at the moment another
distinction is that they don't just
target a single epitope of cd19 like the
cars do instead they target three
different tumor associated antigens so
even if there's a immune escape of one
of those you still have two more
antigens that you can target and we're
not targeting a single peptide which is
agent a restricted you know it allows
for the cells themselves to select the
best targets depending on the HLA type
so it's not actually restricted it
targets three different proteins which
prevents immune escape and it has a
better safety profile for a program
building a new cell therapy facility
what are some of the biggest obstacles
they'll have to overcome yeah I touched
on this earlier it's easy or easier to
pinpoint what you will need to do in the
facility but one of the challenges and
one of the surprises that I had when we
started our facility was all the
components that are not directly under
my control so we needed access to an
irradiated and that was not in our
facility so I had to work with the blood
bank and they've been they've been a
great team player but that's a
relationship that we had to make a
concerted effort to build
you know environmental services so the
people who clean your facility not
something you typically think of but
that's also challenging because you know
they don't understand the importance of
what you're doing and so we've really
made an effort to bring those people
under our wing we have educational
sessions for them we you know we order
some pizza we explain to them the
importance of what we do we say hey look
there's patients coming from across the
country to get ourselves and we're
potentially saving their life and it's
really important and I think they've
started they've started to buy into that
you know I I hear now our EBS directors
say you know dr. Patrick you know I
think it's it's great I know that we
need to clean this better because you
know the last thing I want is my kid to
die from an infection that they acquired
because we didn't clean well enough and
so that to me indicates that we've
successfully educated them so really
it's the ancillary components that are
really challenging to build the other
thing is you're not like everyone else
so you're not the blood bank you're not
laboratory medicine
you're not hematology and so you have
unique needs so what if you're using lab
medicines drooly testing for example you
know that's been validated for a blood
test they don't understand why you want
to hold it for 14 days if they've
already validated it for five so you
know I can give you a whole list of
these challenges or during you know you
you order what you need in a facility
like this we don't have a lot of storage
space and someone else who places the
order decides to double it because they
don't want to they don't want to order
it every week so you know you have to
have tight process can control as part
of good manufacturing practices and into
that was an example where we realized
that we didn't so yeah I think it's more
the parts of the facility that aren't
under your control that are really
surprising and unexpected well I was
like to once again thank dr. Hanley for
his presentation do you have any final
comments no I think I just want to thank
everybody for taking the time to listen
to the presentation if you have any
questions feel free to reach out to me
directly and I think this is a really
exciting field to be in right now and
I'm proud to be a part of it
well thanks again I'd like to thank the
audience at you for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor two-room o BCT for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through April 2018 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that you know we're colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye